in kolkata the world's fastest warming
city
climate announcements made in glasgow to
make headlines at
home net zero by 2070 that's the promise
by the indian prime minister
welcomed by world leaders
met with a bit more skepticism in a city
already feeling the effects of climate
change
because of global warming the winters
are not
over here it's still summer and it's
like so hot
so i think it should be earlier as
possible as we can and the people should
do better
foreign
[Music]
india's 2017 net zero target is the most
distant of any g20 nation but the task
for this country still lifting millions
out of poverty is huge
this is the nitty gritty of getting to
net zero because of course the net zero
target of 2017 for india means an entire
overhaul of its energy sector but it
also means looking at issues like this
making sure that jobs and livelihoods
like sanjays that rely on coal
alternatives have been suggested
doubling down on solar investing in
green hydrogen it's a start but there is
much further to go
if you look at other economies like the
us which is has all the technological
might and the uh finance available has
committed in 2050 right and if china is
committed to 2016. so india's 270
doesn't appear uh too delayed to me if
you look at practically and if we have
to really step up that i think that
funny has to come in from the developed
world they should commit more and that's
how india can probably speed up further
its low carbon development plan right
india is committed to a target it now
wants the finance one trillion dollars
from developed countries for the
developing world
for places that didn't benefit from the
industrial revolution and don't want to
get left behind in the green one
sky news in kolkata